you've been traveling a lot recently you
went to istanbul yeah
i just got i went to istanbul uh last
week and uh just for the
hell of it you know i've never been
there i have no idea what a symbol is
like uh it's
you know i like to think that i'm a
world traveler i feel like i kind of
went because i'm cheap
because
i knew that
istanbul straddles both asia and europe
so i knew that i could kind of knock
both those out with one trip sure
it's like i landed on the european side
that i took a boat across and i was in
asia and i was like done bucket list
[Music]
my bucket list
my criteria for my bucket list is super
low
i i checked off uh you know meeting
conan from meeting a celebrity okay
that's not
that's just wrong it's true it's true
that's just wrong that's a very very
narrow view of the world to say uh i
know i've been to asia and you're europe
uh no i did i went through some very
very cool uh you know of course the
ottoman empire was run out of it for 600
years and uh uh an amazing place uh i
went to the the palace there where they
have the harem
you know the the sultan could would keep
a harem hundred hundreds of women in
various degrees of like one he'd have uh
he'd have multiple wives and the
you know to get the next sultan
presumably um but the whole thing was
run the harem at any given time was run
by these eunuchs
which is pretty like bad you know they'd
castrate these guys and then be like
okay now you can you're in charge of all
these women
which seems pretty cruel yeah think
about it yeah they would he would take
away their uh ability to
you know and then
and then go and now you get to go hang
out with all these ladies
which seemed kind of awful it'd be like
you know saying hey here's a bunch of
candy but we're going to sew your mouth
shut yeah yeah
no
it's pretty like saying to andy like
here's a bunch of booze and like
oh just here's a bunch of booze
yeah you uh you've worked with andy on
the millers i did work with andy and i
did uh what was that he embarrassed me
he embarrassed you what are the rules
around here about drinking during the
day because like
andy thinks he's in europe or something
i mean
half the day's you know he's half in the
bag and he's showing up and he's goofing
on his lines it was
man i tell you it was rough but anyway
we've got we got him through
no actually truthfully andy had to do a
uh a pole dance yeah a pole dance and
when is this going to air it's already
been on
friend yeah thanks a lot
[Music]
two
it'd be bad enough if it was just one of
us
but both of us
both of us were on it two of your
closest friends ever
he called me uh after it aired and was
like what did conan say
nothing nothing nothing i feel i feel
bad now i i was
this is the second time
i'm going to go home tonight and i'm
going to watch it it's on my tivo i'd
love to come on this show and not just
cry once but cry twice
i liked you that the reaction to you
crying is people going
hey i have a quick question why were you
uh doing a striptease what's the
dramatic reason for you to be doing a
pole dance uh
you wanted
i played like a loser co-worker of his
that he took under his wing take it easy
and i had um and i had uh uh proposed to
a stripper
thinking that it was a real relationship
and so in my attempt to win her back i
did a pull we went down to the club and
i did a pole dance yeah like you do it's
like that
it's that old storyline that like we
ripped off from green acres yeah you
know all that all that guy goes and does
a pole dance for us i will say again all
bits aside andy was very good at it
very very good
so
that's one of those not-for-nothings
they didn't have to reinforce the pole
though all right all right
i keep moving there there was a woman
that was dancing on it and then when
they found out i was going to be on
they're like well we've got to really
beef up that
the difference watching him do that
really beefed up my pole too
oh yeah awful awful and come on we're
just a couple of dudes hanging out